[Music]
we want enough like around himself in
criticism can you go very fast again ago
we never talked about her go to the
cellar sheshe and everything No
okay we have to wait for him to write a
minute or cereal I mean we've all been
over the mantel representation so I
don't think what's up what are you were
to be here forever well today I don't
want us to lobby and ready okay good so
I'll welcome everyone in the Masters
people present of robbing the bureau and
I won't read it title but he's that is
going to depend his thesis today so as
you know the usual procedure is for the
students to present her then the public
to ask any questions that the public in
suspense and they remain behind anemone
further questions and then you mix a any
decide whether he has simply immense you
all right now thank you all for coming
today i will be presenting my people on
the set for partial music and extra
personal expression in the
identification and publication in
sharples companies so what is perfect
proteomics are the tempo yonex was
appointed mid-1990 she described the
large-scale characterization most of all
the buildings are expecting sell or buy
Russian handful and our master country
in the predominant tool but it refused
in our economic forum mass
spectrometry-based knowledge is the
mathematical equation and way with of
large databases to not only not only not
get a tradition but also for function
mountains and post-transcriptional
modifications and people's interactions
and other structural analysis and
charmin group is the predominant
audiences where protein samples is
digested into effect and that entire
undergoes a rapid chemical analysis for
building accusation so of nina ricci
walking to
typical shot in the young dis clinic it
can be ordered into a three part 3 part
is a sample preparation this is where
our sample is first phagocytes using the
n9 like a personal commentary and then
peptide mixture has been subjected to
are separated using the latest on top
and then part the bible commentary you
look from the personal doctor there's an
eye on achieving it won't take and
representative to the max trauma trees
or habitat resonance we see a little to
this battleground spectrum that is used
for our gardening station and the
national artists presentation where a
wide spectrum is comparing empirical
prospectin and is generated from these
percentages and peppered event mattress
vertical the work that is easily
education far now what you have are the
protein sequence databases which are
basically largely on tourism protein
sequences here for a didn't see and hear
a cnc prsa for a clean start a debate
and undergo a youtube / am using an
inline like a Trojan digestion and that
generating function which would be
assertive for an integration and with on
the the measured map of the perfect a
spiritual trauma denial preference is
generated and then the echo and the
young 30 confession sequestered mascot
these are in school computer via quite
welcome to the series of central and
then of candidness salsa that id0 levin
much for that spectrum and peace can
determine so this can decide
and write it going to a scoring function
and generally be the highest scoring set
by insecurity best match for researcher
and so the spectrum is called the pepper
spectral match are they attend so how
Bobby the peptides are identified and
that one survivor identified the next is
due in four proteins patient we observe
preference and this could be a
challenging process in the sharp end to
be honest because the quad I Jesse you
are you there's a lot of connections
between proteins and peptides now you
generate two kinds of peptides you have
the union's website the user capacitor
masculine single Cody suppresses this
perfect for implants our only link to go
in for surgery because we tell you like
you protein to the sample and then you
can also have shaped our biases easier
conduct that in the master much more
open so they create adequately literally
their parents presence these separate
one and two Titus home uncomfortable
perfect one and two are shape is there
think people protein 180 / title Anjali
travelpod without they belong to 31 or
32 and we shall share them and there
because of the shape peptides yogi
matrons can be deniable competent and
and then you cannot really ignore the
shape of information severe weather
potential operation so what a heavier
are two common scenario of growing
interest and just make sure that
diagnose is talking and conserving our
interface on the observed seven so in
the first scenario here we look
surprises us one two three four and five
and the first one and four and five are
you said we
there we make little single cookie so in
this case because I what is nature
cookie name and as I saw replies are
basically beat and that too many are
shared either make you both proteinate
Angela week the nothing that will offer
disagreeable rotate because each
stroking can be represented by a
different set of setbacks so you're
cooking and discipline was enough to
produce a news report from AK Antony now
you can also have it in distinguish
fulfilling these are to me or grupo a
leader for Google proteins that are
represented by an identical set of that
type so the example we have particularly
in mind right after these for Peppa can
be links to both routine and we need so
he's really not sure if your shadow
campaign see you're able to do near
broken interest in the important as an
individual group there can be both going
to end early so we mean we idea because
of provisions to generate a partner in
little protein or or remove mr.
proboscis account for all the observed
setbacks so one common space is
partially knowledge is to remove pretty
fair except for other buildings and for
instance here in the third scenario i
have peptide 1 2 3 4 5 and all the flash
peptides are linked to protein II and
the eff has wanted to there are later
Fergie net and please forward primer
Lincoln green jeans and here they want
to generate a realistic okanagan all
survived he was only report released
with my logo uses and that angiotensin
sublet of the inner part of the protein
integer so what's how does the specified
degeneracy is in charge and proteomics
one major sources that
underline genomics structure of our and
personally under various organs are
human they may have these long the other
one is want to see because of Smith are
the RNA editing or altered sweating and
other post translational modification
tips oh yeah other for salvation one
occasion that NGOs similar stories
product if you match the month he'll be
connected called web agency another
reason is because of the differences in
the childhood protein sequence databases
that are used in an investigation and to
be honest there are several people carry
a very neatly mtbr irony or the ensemble
or the idea of 59 work whether you are
happy that's very in mass comm business
and marriage invention so depending on
the surveying the building Saturday's
relative in hospital that effect i think
matched multiple proteins so p why our
presentation or my pieces i have a
contest for overly religious today the
first goal is to understand if the
growing sequence databases from
different sources are actually different
so what I'm looking at our protein and
peptide narrow differences across
databases and and the payment Melinda's
compare and contrast these differences
between higher you various problems and
lower detectors work and so for higher
eukaryotes I chose about human and
months and fur elise 276 of govt
complexity in these arms and the second
goal that service to understand these
types of protein sequence databases from
different sources on anomaly or
biological samples and there is very
little difference between fully
democratic repetitive distinguishable
and non distinguishing talking counts
and also has a little cat
set about shade and unique momentum and
the question of interest here is the
sequences are does the caution when we
body hadn't used in the Scorpion
interest brothers are you stroking out
that are independent of the protein
sequence s if the number of proteins are
identifiable and establish in an
intrinsic property of examples / 2010
example and should be relatively
descendant of the ER broken incredible
so the grant gold here eventually will
understand but we are going to implement
these clustering algorithms which are
incensed and extension to be our basic
parsimony nodded and we wanted to see
how this extender carson one discussion
changes the effects of protein sequence
database on protein another
characteristic and we've implemented two
different variations of the protein of
these clustering algorithms and what
they do is they're they're implemented
after the protein infant size to reduce
the parsimonious officials early and the
way they work is they group proteins
with high shape that by david and that
low unique at that mm so depression of
interfering ended does this extended
partial any question for you stroking
towns that are independent of the
protein content and finally the last
whole event to understand how the
quantitative information changes with
respect to the changing building
products and you are my resolution you
how the definition of jeannie and
sheriff guys change that respect to the
basic pressure moving object and also
trepidation Department question so we're
computer this method call be the qrt are
the quantitative information content
which would be the ratio of the unique
PMF part of see all the identifiable
p.m. and what was the t is the low
resource the dependent typ on these
charges
deputies and may be partial results and
X is partially country so before I buy
me when I want to go over definition of
the term that are we living in early to
elude the baby wish for cooking
improving their protein thread
represented by a distinct set of that
night and then in commercial buildings
are those are in 25 and animals vs Shiva
that each arm at arbitrary map working
will uncle tony and the Indy 500
overnight were being cookie or overly so
other person dinagat is the about
growing and park at katra sets from
logical fetishes and the children are
for sequence data both consumers sister
renovation for social for human
mountainous and my resume should really
be comparing demon and decluttering and
so we have import database that contains
does destruct manually curated and
highly Adam Tina database and then you
have a tremble which has an addition of
protein sequences times it doesn't have
a condom ever curation man annotation as
this is protected and then finally happy
the I become static the user base will
be seeing additional that way that
contains several treasures of all the
criteria for a row community and in
addition to you Russ we also chose the
NCBI are take away the uncle of a
debating the IP i have is olivier not
currently using more and we saw that the
yeast doesn't have a nice
they all that resentment is on Chris
dual-pane being laundered and every come
on isn't there some other things all the
engagement good night and so that
there's one get new record over one
hundred percent I am porcelain sequence
for a given community those would be an
honor in cooking class and then we also
perform an infinite or terrific
digestion and computer the correct
address before we completely changed and
unique that I count to meet religious
context it is will here to cover between
different data recorder patients the
secret item and also contrast between
higher and lower entire surface so the
address difficulty planning well what I
have here is the reticle non reinventing
in camp between human different
databases and release different that
business and the ladies are discounts to
the UT drug reference chromium which is
indicated by massive great speed and
what we found so that there is a high
very ready in chromium across she larger
that way discussed on the tremble and
this is rather the trouble the divisor
want that base has almost twice as many
proteins as the baby person and then the
other from you having shorter data such
as the central admin and is only about
one-third leader
infinity actual non-tournament tongue
people discover every bit as only like
eight thousand cooking while making when
you add the additional when you add the
thermal a bit you're the number becomes
both before and the addition the iso
contract they add another twenty
thousand protein so in a point is that
there's a lot of variability in the
routine come across different protein
deputies however may look at the East
databases you don't do that kind of very
pretty or something tom foley you know
he's very good designers are really
communicating between different of each
season setting and so you did a great
characteristic there are different
abuses that it only wants do with
appropriate activities you could short
time ago humans hello a perfect andhra
pradesh allah so the gray bars the
doctor we marched here Arnie the total
net by accounts across human being
infected and the light degree are those
were all about ESP senses to target that
there is a lot more as i found a truant
human habitability and something more
interesting is that there's a lot of
variability in these peptides town
across Sheena Natalie no you happy this
is what idea that have approximately 2.4
million that I think while a larger that
it has a little over three get over
there is no such variability in the heat
going there all right now
2004 the shade nice proportions and the
lack circles that you see here are the
shared a high proportion who may eat on
imaging system status and the white
circles are totally eat being settings
and that the office differences and we
found that on average there is the
sheriff at reported community but to be
beaten compared to believe Lackey
burgundy and told me about the deal
complex be inserted in living here
really deep and also endured a lot of
variability initiated after for
opportunity in tactics many will because
this truck has only like they're in
decent shape reporting is very similar
to what we observe in that in a easy
with that and talk about their debris
over in this message right at it as
Americans the other you know the lunches
are you want to run that over sixty
percent shaker high proportion so so why
are shooting that there are permanent
residence in throwing for any different
King growing team offense to what what
you see how this is so confident or
provisions of attachments dangerous
business and not available for example
because real biological samples will be
contain a small proportion of proteins
that you will reserve in in the
community perspective and and also their
their businesses including abundance in
real life examples here with no
political instability identified by a
small number
and because proteins are infrared based
on the observe that I'd rather intimate
or mitigating the equities become
royalty that basis so what we want to
know is if the protein effect actresses
are actually super angry I also tell as
we workers in protein park in Rio for
Indian panties so um doesn't do things
the raw mass spectrometry data from
publicly available with data sets of
human lab results mouth Cicotte culture
self and yeast cosas lighting and event
into a search those against different
species specific articles databases that
are solutions previous life and then
we're committed the protein inference
with the baited partially dodge to be
removed asian profit per means of the do
we generate a final quite one is list of
proteins within our biological sample a
perfect analysis so that we were they
able to compute it really bad person
because be the missing ritual and
individual individual growing account
and at the same time we also a computer
suffolk addresses from mass the
commentary data that were better at
mystic slightly initiate and really
perfect so the relatives total rookie
council real biological chemicals this
is the relative protein count in human
and yeast samples across different
databases a individual learners who were
actually really what we found with this
and there's a lot of variability in the
number of grantees are identified across
different building treatment at bakers
when researchers sample a larger
dominators nitrous Ross and me tremble
or fish caught in trouble with the ipod
objective you found almost twice as
improving for example as when searching
NC made reference and being the others
and certainly open search against hard
at really only found but this generation
of the building committee found the
runner however of cognitive differences
in each sample projects value so again
how throwing demons Kenny different with
humans compared to eat and when we look
at the distinguishable protein reporting
in real biological samples the lighter
gray bars here in de the definitional
for reporting season in the each samples
across Saturday's of energy there are 99
or ninety nine percent faulty proteins
are essentially in each hassle than
there's no jewelry that they're all
human centipede growth different values
whoever we need tell me percent of the
killings are suitable for use energy
analysis that because they're usually a
lot of variability of across Saturday
and in them in early as a smaller decade
by Christmas parted ways that have for a
98-percent disease will repeat or area I
detrital remind users compared to much
larger data difference
the general may be about fifty percent
distinguish working portion prolly yes
what's your definition of a distinctive
approach teachers will be there of a
represented by but distinct said don't
have time okay unless they're they're
immigrants we're there in the end he
goes right there we were able to
collapse multiple proteins into a single
group rescue called CBS Inc called us in
your purview claddagh it would that be
distinguishable protein for when it be
eliminated from now the so-so the
pleasure's whether distinguish will need
help using it the latest all the info
you have need one thing look out they're
sending all the group or basel covina
indistinguishable from ingles so if you
have ten rupees within a native english
full of protein 10 bb10 31 is modern in
this protein counter coated to let up
wait so again what we see in that
there's a there's a lot of variation to
be any man because we see that they're
being the human that other one complex
man becomes and also that there really
should be the redundancy to the Houston
Texas comparative probably easy offense
so now we need to determine
characteristics in math the real
biological samples what we notice is
that the trends are very similar will be
observed from the Intel Core digestions
of the protein sequence databases the
darker gray bars here are the shape of
that reference to the human samples
across
he's a traitor the lighter gray are
those for the East Africa and what you
notice that the shape of metaphors over
to meet the real human samples on
cognition that it was released we're on
to engage in the comic width and height
are larger arena leaders have much
higher ship survivable for living be ten
summers is a much more so so what I've
shown you so far is that you know there
are growing and halfpipe level
difference of Stephen in real biological
samples officially in the human travel
across different databases and your when
research or example against larger
database we found a valid for inward
proteins in our battle colleges and
server depositors in a smart acne but in
reality a sample consists of a set
number of protein juice and remember
protein burger in the Apple II only
depended on language interpreting
amenities going TM status genuine or and
cut across in Python will defendant may
use the same sample never forgive me and
my research them against different robux
even statuses and incremented of protein
impressed with the basic marketing
opportunity cookies of it and will be
prominent there were a variable general
Loki Tom god damnit which trim it really
happened and to be a nationally math and
other information you know more peptides
are being identified now and so
actually pulling in sight and showing
that you know the basic partially gothic
here actually observing a variable
number of identical are available number
of protein to the paint sample it is
suggested that you know perhaps that the
baby partially logical partitioning up
litter the attention to this is a bottle
and for that reason to all commercial
what the plan was implemented clustering
ought to be recharged second extension
to the other personal projects and the
moment in your ear you have protein real
pro teams that have hygiene aside aliens
and no repayment we wanted to see how
that will be applied these amazing
apartment wrestling on how it will
affect protein and doesn't address is
necrotic and so the personal done with
intimate and test the part where in
algorithms on real biological samples
and polishing algorithm actually part be
provided in the oldest people work and
as I mentioned earlier the the
clustering algorithm is implemented
after decoding interest process of the
latest parsimony logic so it makes use
of the the protein and ease of the
peptide reports that are generated from
ingredients and it performs a pairwise
comparison of proteins that share the
East out cup tied to that for clustering
and based on the unique and shades of
tight circle cap there are three ways
that a pair of proteins can be quartered
you can have pseudo religious cultures
circular in dense clusters by the the
red boxes here indicate unique type
between box
or the party shape at night so in pseudo
redundant clusters if the two proteins
have low leaked that there until they
have a maximum of two spectral counts
but there are shared that I speckled
ounces at least 10 times the unique
event the truth of these are soccer
together as children in the logic here
because that gives this unique attack
evidence hi Dada extent the little
protein for them in concert and
indistinguishable from a group rate on
the bass part English and then you can
also have pseudo website lockers and it
is if one protein has a really small
unique the dinosaur Matthew
opportunistic account but has
significantly shared purpose to
literally 10 times the mini covered in
it that if the distro games because
they're under sudo something of other
cookies in a lot of years but that it
really kept items and unrestricted and
this routine have industrial puppet and
it will not happen would it be the very
be sent for by a parting another and
then finally you have shared spectra
cluster synthesis where if two cookies
have a significantly large shape that
I've ever compared to disney
protectiveness than their worship their
shades echo cancellation moving on the
babies are 3 of X couch then it's
plotted together shaped bedroom and
whenever pair of cronies are requested
together their their present in a single
entry and the unique and
that counts are computing and this is a
Christian include some of the stables
and rook engine royalty so you didn't
reconcile covina service category with
individual crooked and server and
kristen and human samples but with the
accomplishing algorithm so what we see
here is a sphere it is the human
dimension there you ok the humans
distinguish protein count in human
examples across all databases and the
black circle here are the protein comes
after the basic parsimony logic and the
white circles are alpha be pop when we
gathered and the obviously old exhibit
upon the eight o'clock honest when he
needs a talk mr. gathers there's a
decently we usually one for equality so
industry that know if they gave it
events of the building team status on
three counts pause button type or be
noticed was that deep the variations
condizioni account have doctors fifty
percent the deviated cardinal rigali to
only five percent the you didn't policy
now and now you can be the effective
publish now on right the black is black
circle here indicate the shared peptide
proportions in the human samples across
all databases with amazing harmonia
logic and the white circle are the
awesome
put that the shape of it quickly on all
the nightly would be hotter than hell
and on the debt that are very thought
that I'd leaders have also found with
the mall and municipal here that meet
their identity could be made upon you
not cool but you've gone down but I
don't under you know here is the
definition of shared up guys how it
changes with context of invading
partially on it shaped eyes are
intersecting each supporting into their
respective accreditation cookies are
indistinguishable pro giggles and now
when you introduce him are depressing
related fashion personality now their
respected clusters of Henry what is
pretty the venom our agreement cluster
together all their shipment as the
amount because their genes oversee
things they change their work and also a
nucleus which will later use for
quantification vs in addition to in
addition to the the publishing algorithm
it won't want to placate other plugins
are relatively sure and compare Dennis
publishing Ellen and you are their
projects only find one publication by
the Lakers of NASA and there's another
software technical manual but neighbors
cats and so the example that they
provided the technical and will be
returning to hold infinite versions of
these scattered personalities and
opposite that's very similar to deposit
committed again after tea the protein
incest logic and we're good in purple of
pairwise comparison of relief that
shared that I defense for public and
Mikey popular thing on the because
reincarnation is pretty simple if to
believe confirming their culture with
this year eighty percent on their second
so the very traitor method of clustering
and every additional to me is certainly
added to an existing culture if that
protein shake and each position at with
the upload easy with an atmosphere so
what becomes in minooka the appropriate
avec actresses in here saxophone and
nothing very similar is allowable term
property and be my turtle here
resistance dedication to keep an
albertsons inc camera there is a
introduction be very living a rookie
comes from a dentist in fact will be
noticed with the very bedrock drop the
attendance the baby's arm only 120 PS
110
okay to the mother strongly princess
theatre partially Russian and actually
needed be unattended indian mallu me and
i will you get the [ __ ] that recording
after implementing need this Apple Mac
Cullen be some of the main shares of
that proportion has dropped from three
point five percent with the basic
parsimony logic to only one point one
percent would be a scaffold I question
again there's a very good consistency
across that way with the catalyst so now
that we've been connected these
questioning algorithms we also wanted to
understand if the clusters that are
generated from these algorithms have
some kind of a biological meaning to
them and you know so these structures
generated from that is Muslim there's no
more functional or biological
similarities and so we look at some
internal for evaluation and there are
progressed the natural capital
revolution viva mayr be the cyllage
scored of those clusters and then the
third quarter is a little competition
that measures me the consistencies and
clusters of beta so for each from inside
the physics core faculty is we it's a
measure of how similar fat protein is
this members of its own combustor
compared to how separated naturally is
members of the slowest memory clusters
so in a way of comparisons of cohesion
to separation and what was that
piranhas all so global pairwise
alignment of all of the proteins that
are present within a therapist and the
cluster size of two or more and from
that we were able to compute the
similarity scores for all pairs of
probation adulterer and from the
similarity scores you're going to
computer this is my informative Lima
from airport and then reviews that
discipline for the business metrics for
the famous for computation and then we
were been able to compute the mean too
much force for all the factors that were
generated by either the boss once
Kaepernick pattern and that kind of give
to the measure of how to ikea routes
during and something to note here is the
sailors coronation native one composite
want to the higher value he wore aryan
the GUI is located through whole cluster
spent with me great enclosure so what we
found was that these apples i have
generated quite entire colony to enforce
that he wanna bring everything we have
the need the need to restore bridge the
gap where they ever throw all that in
point 59 compared to you he talked about
1.0 be hired by decision that you know
these cultures are acting kinda cool and
superior GC is the comparison will be
jewish bush in human samples and you
notice the lack of indicators in the
course for Kaepernick others and a white
harvard upon the famous words our treaty
of sinners of all that is efficient for
the largest that means that responds in
tremble
and this leaks that region needed
because of how the tall and awkward my
album are different in the past I think
I would Jesus the unique tendencies
there's sufficient beautiful veterans to
fall instructor so it can work we can
share a veteran discount warehouse and
the really big rope was weak imperialism
you do context that's all for the
clustering and so what we mean is that
for you to larger databases to be larger
help they're pretty large economies of
the populace in algorithms we found that
out of several cultures there can be
received kind of growing up there can be
a true saddam hussein family goes for
instance he could find several mfc
clusters so it's possible that octob
better step it within one energy motor
could be located completed leave a
message another limit instructor so
because of that it probably be the
students for value however was a scatter
like on all the MHC who will be one big
cousin so in the neighbor cutter via
computation an IED there's such an
amazing holy and mighty was Ruby
Negron on a cluster so in addition to
using some inherent features or Intel
about using World War get some external
evaluation and janitors we had a rifle
or a puncture too many civilians
electric Stanford that with performs
Gina dishes not be sustained there's any
kind of biological or functional
tannerite with his growing and so what
has done for every for every cruelty for
any protein for every [ __ ] sweater
we've okay all the laundry 94 the sodium
structure and from that they were then
able to locate all the Geo terms for
both eyelashes ontology family my dear
conscience option and you know
background fit your were then able to
identify significant can share you earn
Frizzle not obvious it in that cluster
so what we found was that in majorca
cultures that were used for gene
efficient analysis they had been easy
returns for both biological copies and
medical terminology however it didn't
notice that a lot of clustered petrol be
to the same author is gie are also that
some clusters didn't have proteins with
an hundred tiny so because of that we
have to interment an in-house school
there's only a flutter two things to
unique opportunities were actually
eligible for the Egyptian Palace and by
doing so we found with a lius modern
performance of all these clusters that
were generated refuse or eligible for
even return our children would weaken
fibrin
these clusters our initial division
example either top or the cat work well
together however what is the bed also
status 100 maybe send five percent often
structure detect significant Jeter for
either on a show-stopping work or what
is it functional talking to the first
adjustment our fuzzy absolute did
generate Rogers short or functional
pieces and not just purely based on fact
and so if using that will put simple
although machinima trend analysis so
what I have here is a pro each cluster
that was generated using of the cloth
listening algorithm with the human
samples that were purged against a cbi
refseq database to this cluster has be
buried we've been able to obtain the
entrees t-90s there are three unique on
50-90 and those this would be considered
and original project is done how to keep
community auditions and wasn't invited
but all the geo terms this will be is
the conditional and the background said
I need all the proteins that were
identified after the proven innocent
using the NCBI risky gambit and got all
these all the energy I need social
inclusion business children and being
are going to compute the uncorrected p
values for each geo term using the
fisher exact test and then it was much
focus granted
with the avenging awkward Pegasus and
the odd restriction of 0.3 month so so
poto turns with an assistant p value of
less than 0.05 and that are associated
with quality members of the puncture are
under your statements and in this
example here which I found whether there
were seven signification children and
they're all related to cell division or
gtp-binding and if you look at the
permeability in succession the property
story not isn't even public appearances
of matches the Shiva temptation becomes
you and i hope you how our clusters are
actually quite logically and finally we
also look at the effects of qia and with
changing grouping context so this
computer's creditor computed is
inserting 15 LCD the equation you might
be exactly the ratio of the unique PSM
but a body a 10-5 gsm and in that and
then compute that you señor need to
compare this method of those qnt across
30 people standing and waiting for
anybody and excellent as many countries
so you notice that we can challenge the
queue ID is active and they use gsm so
there are pieces scenario for the effect
you can have some time led to entire
growing season staff pages to read
sometimes very needed people throwing
entries that it might excite to be
entirely sympathetic or you have such a
journey after a basic seismological
inner fender we need to a pita to
derivative equal then finally you can
have that back there he needs a
predicted apartmani touch things so
these would be secondary to be published
so what we found was that the joisey is
benefiting improved with the station
Department offering scheme battles here
shows EG y demas different because I
scenario the fridge the person
narratives are the priority to cooking
enemies and the better he have to keep
cutting across differently but there's a
lot of the key export and the larger or
smaller decorations of his miss part IV
had a much greater VIP already even
smaller battery works wasn't written
test
however could be implemented the extra
cosmic clustering so I immediately
tokidoki be protected there are also
much Hydra qi t IG across all databases
so what we had years after the prom you
need capital so do i see after addition
and marginally closing the right on the
point money and the apartment and 130 so
they did a summary media prometheus
databases from a different source
produced scissors protein and FFA
actresses who r each other there's a
high variability in the knowledge that
mentally count and share the better
portion in humans even that measles and
we also found similar growing in traffic
characterization valentino samples so we
implicitly hurry necessitated partially
funded that in unit Soviet Counter
hemostat other action dependent on the
occurrence in session however we
submitted the effects Department present
in the form of a pause Kaepernick
evidence it's significant here to see
the variability the week and that
potential in the future and also be in
the party person has created defense of
Soviet expenses and tea time the
cultures were generated from these
actresses were not only group based on a
beverage
had a very superb by multifunctional
community and finally the means you I
believed that Cygnus cookie cutters for
a gym battle raged across one country
nowhere to run the EV are going on and
at times 10 different decision to depart
when you talk to get any negative
effects of intent on the EQIP life so
wondering the conclusions here how do we
how this question Galatea practically
you can do you see the agent partially
covering that part of you eat barking
pipeline are Hercules use a regular
parsimony profit with the simplest
creating content and based on I have
show jeans my recommendation is that for
well protein expression citizens human
life the basic parts will be bonded with
the Espada 15 no sure given this is for
that we have relatively bad incompetency
so what however this movie this is
programa students contains all the
hydrogen ariat work so if you use a
nonhuman non mount a higher eukaryotes
then it's recommend that you use a more
comfy aggravated as the additional
content and you we use much
on the face of airline identified in for
18 assists and also in management and
affiliation is part one person to as a
supplement to the debate especially in
the north diversity community center so
alluring action litigation Murray the
apartment wrestling with that gentleman
greetings and minus and we don't know
effect on other higher eukaryotes
cordless and at the same time if we
don't know how this extended personally
clusterings would perform when it's a
blast to sequence databases for samples
that were digested that not risen go he
will only perform on person that you're
succeeding and it will be 4i support
then it's recommended that you not use
the sequence conservation department
project that they were possible to that
body I don't want to be touching if you
want to sing and in finally let us paint
my thesis committee the corner dr.
Wilmott not approach it really really
helpful throughout the entire piece of
work and if we she added to my list of
God's gift and I also like to thank dr.
Shannon mcqueeney and i am dr. Lynch
walls and of all my DVD classes and my
professorship thank you thanks four
o'clock I'm good luck the reservation
operation very actually question yeah
one do you know a single protein is i
Jes to umm if the actual ratio of the
peptide and the mapping one two one two
one two one and it anytime then then how
robust is the idea of the parsonage
function
and if they are then then can you should
become with the brains of the first
question the question is can meet on a
given cell type only a portion of the
actual construction can be available you
got another fun but especially rather be
in the entire database I mean if you
filter down to the subset of proteins
are actually expressed wear jeans I
threat to that change circle keep such
official account from this so well I and
for your second question I think they
wanted me to ability to perform within
an hour meeting on authorities of
different stuff and you know right now
both over leaders comparative a
department
media session for talking tons of
business that is intentional
we have another six minutes for
questions to your bottle you're showing
difference between imitation of you so
in focusing with that big for inception
yes ok ok so I was just curious and I
know you don't have slides for it but
Jesus for me they now see on Mike and if
so does it look a lot more like the
human a lot more like human but it
doesn't really sound that with their
life the actual identification don't
have absolutely i think i think what was
in here you're seeing here with the
difference as you alluded to is that the
biological complexity there's a lot of
differences between human beings and
these genomes in there a big difference
in nothing thighs these have actually a
whole lot fewer tu trong um them
depending on the papers you later say
don't have introns or their sense of
subset of genes and the trunk that you
imagine without n times you're going to
really affect how many different
isoforms you out which is very compact
analyses rear shotgun proteomic so it's
going to different for a pattern there
but i would imagine the mice the
difference of your scene between the
punishment of human i'm guessing
probably has more to do with how well
curated the databases are from mice
perfect that's all and all that could be
that he 11
their Christmas party with it yeah I
think I think you sort of you've got
real biological differences between for
instance but you've also got sort of
database and just how much we empower
and dumped into characterizing them did
you know really effective because that
time counterparts of coming events were
required identification of one person to
Miami campaign uh how many the peptide
features require in order to admire
protein ohh so one of the partially
principles in that prevent Iran action
so in order to another be some
impressions lauderdale generated the
street that much as i do and also easier
to do this and the bullhead city happy
how long were you here I'm tired of hair
like seven of us and and from directly
these guys were just random slices out
of the folding of your protein not
really meant various there's an arginine
might even comment couple of the
nitrogen has run some type of 30 foot
what is exhibited qi p value would have
a huge base infirmary requalification
cooking oh then she went to see if I
what evidence did agree that it was did
you be more for any loss i don't i don't
have alexs the tnt identification
which costs I how we're going to do a
thing works better if you are looking
straight up riddles they're both equally
good and yes there's articles computers
is a very limiting employee count and
automatic ocean it doesn't mean I've
ever human the pot maybe it's actually
the very end example very good anyone
what's your interest rate of your body
much making your cooking inference list
even smaller than perhaps use enamored
with all these large investors for
navajo me sooner rooms would be one big
one to choose for building and
quality I'll training area bridge Oh
both i wanted to show here is that with
the basic parts of the project there is
we have a coordination process can see
why i have a shocker there the protein
of count yet cohesion and compared to
what be my mental health and the ratings
are up there behind promotional plan
leash and indicted by looking at how
Housing Trust has a sentence
lasers in some packing for home FN on
that help is more to serve as a
foundation
okay thank you very much I'll get your
bed welcome yeah yeah and then shaking a
little weight is usually where i get
your brilliance more and then then you
go out conversation one fun way back
when you were proposing ideas like that
one of the things you are we're looking
at maybe we were too great for database
that i might do different please work
amid rumours i want to thank early on
people came up a lot of different ways
that i have to make each what databases
besides just looking was reversing
they've been shuffling multiplan randall
and keep in shape and are very sharp i
have time Markov chain model and i'm an
untroubled that's not kind of abandoned
surely arms so why do you think that was
what was the problem with what kind of
random measure important people
specifically a deeper little bit
although many times i speak with your
enemy could match target apexi duty for
that many an entire did you suddenly
palatable to the chance that any of that
really meant 0 0 so it's not the faculty
you might get a target open it yet very
much it's on that thing's think about
the peptide characteristics here you got
a big database my are most of your pet
types different in your real sequences
or most of the thing they are the higher
feel your birthday Oh aren't chickaphant
PS busy
alright but your coffee cameras is not
included in that way to count your time
when I free million jump exempt I some
big database as an honor that that cat
like 11 million this is absolutely
indian right so so are most of your
peptides different almost your top
choice the same like negative one one
question mostly different unique j ok
here's one protein or yelling kill on
sight we need to truly gorgeous be your
target proteins how how often are they
saying satellite infirmities from human
Amadeus Asia become a different location
the role of them is going to be the same
immense multiple proteins or ventricular
is attacking police nice imaging very
low key and weighs rajendra so i hope
you grab the market everything you think
that situation still going to be true
it's so I don't know so with your number
to decoy database entry a decoy tryptic
peptides perhaps no longer match your
target on your clean to have a
one-to-one we should comprehend because
of executives event and you which
believe what would you want to do it the
decoy business is just a question your
cousin because because it's like one of
those spirits is your questions where
the simple answer is kind of like one of
the better efforts can flirt all the
properties you want as a decoy database
all right
dy patil our database that looks like
the protein database along some measures
right one of those reservoirs they can
be you have seen length distribution of
missiles and at the other end and equal
member so we have happened to a simmer
and generally talk about redundancy like
she wanted to say proportional amino
acid i'm looking probably what to think
please bill what you might remember
factor so you need to worry about it was
a natural log k that's exciting if we
different masks I don't know her name
yes it's a mess how many you make a
randomized database that matched your
target anyway the reversing is kind of a
nice simple way that they've done it
before you can anything like you're
worried about kar conversions of cap
about fifty percent of the time then you
got this long go to applications you why
I should very we should hit 311 spend
another lesson flipping them most common
method of creating energy high yeah I
wonder what if you wanted to do a test
against an eclair database ten times
only got one way to make a reverse
database
perfect so you do it with this you tell
me to PR for every x nu into a corner on
the number of that human home or the
situation like yeast your décor
databases is not big enough to provide a
proper challenge against incorrect
mattress to your target database here if
you're looking at six or seven thousand
sequences of the thing and in it in a
state-of-the-art experiment you can
identify four or five thousand projects
that's almost all of your target
database so you don't really have a very
big source of distraction we only have
seven thousand equate sequences maybe
you want ten times indeed equal tables
and how do you manage it kinda can make
you know ten easy decoy databases with
all other debt properties that are all
business I never thought about this
either so maybe the thing to make better
for your question really you're gonna
come here probably depend on this no
limit there's no mail about it but if
you have it perfect you can even
generate as one set of because i had a
little bit effective it is intended in
the period going to complete each meal
as it isn't perfect so that you know you
still have the same one if you're mad
that is so perfect do you have a decoy
database here and and what you do is
each pepper energy we're headed it you
can shuffle this website here so that
another guy in the second big one at
that we have the same protein sequence
or for seeing me on as a day compatible
okay over there is a chance with the
shuffle rashad decoy is
match 20 times I could be better than a
minute he went we needed theoretical
digestive things encounters that what
data structure Python did you use to
keep practicing I you keep missionary so
if you digest the protein to start just
all your proteins and you make a
dictionary the peptides what you then do
with that declarative peptides terms
make it equal hit the send you home
chapel there and then you can put the
decoys back together